[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen die
Frauenfußball-WM und mehr gleich von
Norbert Lehmann einen schönen guten Tag
von mir und bange Blicke zum brennenden
Frachter
die nordseeingefahr ein Frachter mit
2500 Auto steht vor Ameland in Flammen
die Angst vor einer Umweltkatastrophe
ist groß
grünes Licht für grünen Wasserstoff die
Regierung will ihn deutlich schneller
voranbringen um vor allem die Industrie
klimafreundlicher zu machen
und Mick Jagger wird 80 der Rolling
Stones Frontmann feiert und rockt die
Bühne immer noch
[Musik]
seit Stunden sind die Rettungskräfte im
Einsatz um zu verhindern dass der
brennende Frachter in der Nordsee singt
unter den geladenen Wagen sind auch
Elektroautos möglicherweise ist die
Batterie eines dieser e-Autos sind Brand
geraten fest steht die Ursache des
Feuers aber nicht der Frachter war in
Bremerhaven gestartet mit dem Ziel
Ägypten er befand sich ungefähr 27 km
nördlich der niederländischen Insel
Ameland als das Feuer ausbrach berichtet
Rauch über dem Wattenmeer die
niederländische Küstenwache macht am
Nachmittag diese Bilder die Free mental
Highway brennt seit Mitternacht seit die
Besatzung das Schiff verließ einige mit
einem Sprung ins Wasser
dadurch wurde für die Männer war es
schrecklich sagt einer der ersten Retter
wir haben eine nach dem anderen
rausgeholt sie sind aus enormer Höhe
gesprungen lassen Sie es mich so sagen
sie sah nicht gut aus schon
Helikopter retten andere 22 Menschen
sind nur leicht verletzt ein Mensch aber
stirbt in dieser Nacht der Brandherd ist
dort wo die Elektroautos standen ihre
Akkus gelten als Brandrisiko doch auch
die Bauweise des Frachters erschwert das
löschen
die Autotransporter kann man sich
vorstellen wie ein großer Schuhkarton
die sind also offen von vorne bis
achtern von Backbord nach Steuerbord und
wenn es auf so einem Deck brennt gibt es
also keine baulichen Barrieren die jetzt
das Feuer oder auch die Idee die
Wärmeübertragung aufhalten Schlepper
kühlen die Bordwände gerade so dass die
Außenhaut nicht reißt der Frachter hat
Schlagseite wenn er kennt hat oder
bricht Drohnen Schäden an der Natur
bitte
mit der Zunahme des Schiffsverkehrs im
Norden von uns steigt doch das Risiko
für unsere Inseln im Wattenmeer wir
müssen noch mehr tun um die Risiken zu
vermindern
und klar ob ein Elektroauto tatsächlich
die Brandursache war aber die neue
Fracht bringt neue Risiken
dieser Welt Schäfers ist für uns jetzt
auf Ameland Isabel wie kommt das Löschen
des Frachters voran
ja also hier so rund 30 Kilometer hinter
mir da brennt der Frachter immer noch
und die Löscharbeiten die gestalten sich
auch weiterhin sehr schwierig das liegt
vor allem daran dass das Schiff so
extrem heiß ist dass niemand auf das
Schiff gehen kann und wenn man von außen
löscht hat man jetzt bedenken dass wenn
man zu viel Wasser an die falschen
Stellen bringt dass das Schiff dann
Schlagseite kriegen könnte deswegen
versucht man gerade sehr vorsichtig mit
Wasser von außen das Schiff runter zu
kühlen zumindest hat man mit Hilfe eines
anderen Schiffes den Frachter derzeit
stabilisiert und auch jetzt gerade vor
kurzem hier ein weiteres spezial-chef
hergebracht was eingreifen könnte wenn
doch Öl austreten sollte was man hier um
jeden Preis vermeiden möchte ist dass
der Frachter singt und deshalb gibt es
jetzt eigentlich zwei Szenarien einmal
dass man das Schiff doch hier über arme
Land wegschleppt aber dafür müsste man
das Schiff erstmal betreten können und
dann gibt es die zweite Option und das
ist den Frachter komplett ausbrennen zu
lassen und das könnte möglicherweise bis
zu Wochen dauern danke Isabel
grüner wasserstoff ist für die
Bundesregierung ein Hoffnungsträger um
das deutsche Energie-System klimaneutral
umzubauen beim Aufbau der nötigen
Infrastruktur drückt Berlin jetzt aufs
Tempo
Rainer Wasserstoff wird per Elektrolyse
aus Wasser gewonnen das unter massivem
Stromeinsatz aufgespalten wird in
Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff ein Teil
dieser elektrischen Energie wird im
Wasserstoff gespeichert stammt der Strom
dafür aus Erneuerbaren spricht man von
grünem Wasserstoff die Bundesregierung
will nun bis 2032 ein Wasserstoff
verteilnetzaufbauen aus bereits jetzt
genutzten Erdgasleitungen die für
Wasserstoff umgewandelt werden und aus
zusätzlichen neuen Leitungen Patrizia
Wiedemeier berichtet
gefühlt das halbe Kabinett tritt am
Mittag vor die Presse nach dem Motto
sieht her wir streiten nicht sondern
gehen gemeinsam voran beim Thema
Klimaschutz die Regierung will ihr Ziel
für die Wasserstoffproduktion verdoppeln
bis 2030 decarbonisieren weg von Kohle
Öl und Gas wasserstoff ist nach der dem
Ausbau der stromgeführten Versorgung der
Netze und der erneuerbaren Energien die
nächste große Geschichte die wir
brauchen um Deutschland zu
dekarbonisieren und damit den Wohlstand
klimaneutral zu erneuern doch ganz so
einig wie sie sich gibt ist die
Regierung dann doch nicht umstritten
bleibt die Forderung der FDP Wasserstoff
auch fürs Heizen und im Straßenverkehr
einzusetzen
für den Verkehrssektor spielt
Wasserstoff eine enorme Rolle wir
brauchen Wasserstoff um insbesondere
unseren Güterverkehr aber auch den
Individualverkehr klimaneutral zu
stellen gefördert wird künftig jedoch
nicht nur grüner anfangs unter anderem
auch blauer Wasserstoff der mit Erdgas
gewonnen wird heftige Kritik von
Umweltverbänden und
wirtschaftsforscherin kämpfert blauer
wasserstoff ist nicht emissionsfreie
kann sogar dazu führen dass noch mehr
Umwelt und Klimaschäden auftreten als
wenn man das fossile Erdgas direkt
nutzen würde deswegen raten wir explizit
davon ab wir sollten nur grünen
Wasserstoff fördern blau oder grün zwei
Drittel des Wasserstoffs wird
Deutschland importieren müssen doch noch
fehlt die nötige Infrastruktur
Milliarden Investitionen werden nötig
sein
und grüner Wasserstoff spielt auch für
die Stahlindustrie der Zukunft eine
wichtige Rolle bisher zählt sie zu den
größten verursachen von CO2-Emissionen
in Deutschland und das soll sich ändern
und dafür sollen auch hohe Staatshilfen
fließen so unterstützen der Bund und
Nordrhein-Westfalen unter anderem den
Konzern ThyssenKrupp beim Umbau die
Einzelheiten von Martin Schiffler und
Ralf Goldmann
noch ist sie eine der klimaschädlichsten
Industrieanlagen in Deutschland das
Stahlwerk von ThyssenKrupp in Duisburg
langfristig sollen die Hochöfen aber
statt mit Kokskohle mit grünem
Wasserstoff betrieben werden doch der
Umbau ist teuer
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck
brachte deshalb heute 2 Milliarden Euro
Fördergeld mit nach Duisburg
und in der größten Förderbescheide
bisher dem größten Förderbescheid in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland dieses Projekt bei
ThyssenKrupp 3 Milliarden Euro übernimmt
der Konzern zunächst selbst das alles um
den CO2-Ausstoß zu reduzieren und später
sogar ganz zu vermeiden wenn unsere
erste Anlage zu 100% mit Wasserstoff
betrieben wird wird sie jedes Jahr 3,5
Millionen Tonnen CO2 einsparen so viel
wie eine Stadt mit 160.000 Haushalten
imitiert
thyssenKrupp ist nicht das einzige
Stahlunternehmen das Staatshilfe bekommt
das Argument deutscher Stahl müsste
wettbewerbsfähig und bezahlbar bleiben
im Vergleich zur Konkurrenz vor allem
aus Asien und auch um Arbeitsplätze im
Land zu halten sagt der Betriebsrat wir
werden in Duisburg beweisen das
Klimaschutz ohne den australisierung
funktioniert wir werden die Duisburg ein
neues grünes Kapitel für die stolze
deutsche Stahlindustrie aufschlagen in
drei Jahren soll die neue Anlage in
Betrieb gehen weitere sollen folgen auch
die öffentlich gefördert der Staat lässt
sich den Umbau der Stahlindustrie so
einiges kosten
10 Tage wurde verhandelt jetzt gibt es
im Tarifstreit bei der Deutschen Bahn
überraschend schon einen Schlichter
Spruch in Potsdam haben der frühere
Innenminister Thomas de Maizière und die
arbeitsrechtlerin Heide Pfarr gerade die
Ergebnis vorgestellt es sieht eine
stufenweise Lohnerhöhung um insgesamt
410 Euro monatlich vor bei einer
Laufzeit von 25 Monaten
fragen wir nach Bayern wie sind die
Reaktionen von der Deutschen Bahn oder
EVG auf den schlichter Spruch
die Vertreter der Deutschen Bahn und der
Gewerkschaft haben hier vor wenigen
Minuten die Annahme empfohlen
die Schlichtung ist ein klassischer
Kompromiss die Bahn freut sich über eine
lange Laufzeit von 25 Monaten die
Gewerkschaft wollte nur zwölf das
bedeutet Planungssicherheit die
Gewerkschaft hat dafür regelrechte
lohnsprünge für untere Lohngruppen
durchgesetzt ein Beispiel
Fahrdienstleiter bekommen alles in allem
900 Euro mehr fast 30 Prozent künftig
soll es auch keine Unterschiede mehr
geben in der Bezahlung von Ost und West
nun wird mit Spannung die uhrabstimmung
erwartet in der Gewerkschaft bis 29 bis
28 August haben die Mitglieder Zeit über
den teuersten Tarifabschluss in der
Geschichte der Deutschen Bahn zu
befinden solange darf auch nicht
gestreikt werden auch das ein Ergebnis
der Schlichtungsrunde hier in Potsdam
dankeschön
fast jeder vierte Beschäftigte in
Deutschland bekommt ein Lohn von weniger
als 14 Euro brutto die Stunde im Oktober
2022 waren es rund 9,3 Millionen
Menschen das zeigen Zahlen des
Statistischen Bundesamtes auf Anfrage
der Linksfraktion im Oktober 2022 war
der Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro festgelegt
worden linken Fraktionschef Bartsch
kritisiert das Lohnniveau sei zu niedrig
wo geflüchtete Menschen unterbringen
eine schwierige Frage für viele Kommunen
hierzulande wie auch für den Ort Upahl
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die Gemeinde
hatte sich lange gegen den Bau einer
Flüchtlingsunterkunft gewährt und einen
baustopf erwirkt es gab auch heftige
Proteste die bundesweit für Aufsehen
gesorgt hatten inzwischen hat die
Landesregierung entschieden dass die
Container Unterkunft weiter gebaut wird
mehr von eine Stadt fällt und Anja
kapinos
sie bereiten den Boden vor der Landkreis
Nordwestmecklenburg lässt auf dem
Gelände in Upahl wieder bauen hier soll
ein Containerdorf für geflüchtete
entstehen Widerstand gegen die
Flüchtlingsaufnahme regt sich schon
lange im Ortsteil der 500 Einwohner hat
die Gemeinde er wirkte vor einigen
Monaten vor Gericht einen Baustopp doch
der Landrat bekam vom Land eine
Ausnahmegenehmigung für den Bau der
Unterkunft
wie viele andere Kollegen in Deutschland
das Problem dass wir eben nicht
ausreichend Plätze haben für die vielen
Menschen die zu uns kommen und ähm
deswegen ist die Unterkunft jetzt ja
auch entschieden worden dass wir nicht
400 Plätze bekommen sondern 250 Plätze
im Januar hatten Gegner der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft versucht in den
Kreistag zu gelangen als dieser die
Unterkunft beschloss auch rechtsradikale
mischten sich unter den größtenteils
friedlichen Protest der reißt nicht ab
auch jetzt hat die Gemeinde Opal erneut
Widerspruch eingelegt will nochmals vor
Gericht ziehen haben viele in der Region
fühlen sich übergangen naja wenn es so
einfach mal über die Bürger hinweg
gemacht wird ich dachte irgendwie wir
hätten noch so ein bisschen was zu sagen
auch es ist es passt einfach nicht kann
schon gebaut werden aber nicht so groß
das denke ich mal außerdem ist ja keine
Infrastruktur nichts in Upahl
Flüchtlinge aus Syrien und Afghanistan
könnten hier ab September unterkommen
dagegen wird am Samstag wieder
protestiert in Upahl
und auch heute richtet sich unser Blick
auf die verheerenden Brände rund ums
Mittelmeer denn Trockenheit Hitze und
Wind fahren immer neue Feuer an
schauen wir uns das auf der Karte an auf
den griechischen Inseln sind einige
Brände unter Kontrolle andere neu
aufgeflammt in Kroatien hat es in der
Nähe von Dubrovnik gebrannt auf Sizilien
ist die Lage besonders schwierig dort
gab es auch Tote auf Korsika sind
inzwischen mehr als 200 Hektar Land
verwüstet und auch Portugal bleibt nicht
verschont dort beginnt der Bericht von
christophell
sindra bei Lissabon es ist schon Abend
als das Feuer gestern ausbricht und klar
ist Löschflugzeuge werden im Dunkeln
nicht mehr starten können es wird ein
Kampf am Boden für alle die dabei sind
fast die ganze Nacht lang
wir versuchen was wir können mit Eimern
viel hilft das nicht
genug wie sich zeigen wird zusammen mit
der Feuerwehr blocken die Bewohner die
Flammen ab Wald einige Hütten gehen
verloren aber niemand wird schwer
verletzt offenbar ein gutes Ende etwa 20
km vor der portugiesischen Hauptstadt
während es in Süditalien weiter brennt
vor allem auf Sizilien bei Palermo viele
einzelne Feuer schwer einzuschätzen
schwer zu löschen und in der Stadt
selbst eine niedergebrannte Kirche
Reliquien Kreuze alles in Asche gestern
zerstört nachdem die Funken von den
nahen Bergen aus übergesprungen waren
erklärt Bruder Vincenzo
der Schaden ist enorm wir haben unsere
Kirche verloren aber Gott sei Dank wurde
niemand verletzt
eben noch Beobachter und plötzlich in
Lebensgefahr wie schnell das geht zeigt
diese Autofahrt bei Syrakus vorgestern
aufgenommen
auch in Kroatien kommen die Flammen den
Menschen bedrohlich nah bei der
Küstenstadt Dubrovnik auch hier erst am
Morgen vorsichtig Entwarnung Feuer wohl
gestoppt 12 km vor der historischen
Innenstadt
weiter bedrohlich bleibt die Lage auf
der griechischen Insel Rhodos seit neun
Tagen brennt es dort und in der letzten
Nacht mussten die Bewohner auf eigene
Gefahr um mehrere Dörfer kämpfen
bleiben wir noch auf Rhodos dort hat
Andreas Postel Feuerwehrleute bei ihrer
gefährlichen Arbeit begleitet rund um
die Stadt Vati im Südosten der Insel
die Feuerwehrleute kämpfen meinen
gefährlichen Kampf gegen die Flammen die
Hitze treibt sie an den Rand der
Erschöpfung hier nahe der Ortschaft wart
ihr im Südosten der Insel versuchen Sie
die Waldbrände unter Kontrolle zu
bringen
wir sind seit drei Tagen hier mit einer
Viertelstunde schlafen die Insel zu
retten jede Pinie zählt für uns und wir
werden das Feuer aufhalten
Ablösung nach einer 24 Stunden Schicht
und kurze Verschnaufpause im Basecamp am
Ortseingang von jenasie hier werden
Brandwunden versorgt Essen und Trinken
gespendet und dazu eine große Portion
Dankbarkeit
es ist für mich aus moralischen Gründen
wichtig hier freiwillig zu helfen für
ein Dankeschön und die Freude in den
Augen der Feuerwehrleute
sie kommen aus dem Ausland aus der
Slowakei und Rumänien zum Beispiel und
werden unterstützt von vielen
griechischen Freiwilligen die ihre
Ortschaften schützen wollen
wir helfen uns gegenseitig aber es sind
so viele feuerfrunden auf einmal immer
wieder brechen neue Feuer hier im
Südosten der Insel Rhodos aus und die
Feuerwehren haben große Schwierigkeiten
die Flammen und der Kontrolle zu bringen
seit dem Aufflammen der Brände vor mehr
als einer Woche stehen gerade einmal 270
Feuerwehrleute auf Rhodos zur Verfügung
das Elend war absehbar sagen sie hier
wir hätten besser vorbereitet sein
müssen mit Brandschneisen mit
Wasserspeichern mit Schläuchen und
Tanklastern
sie richten sich weiter auf
schweißtreibende Tage und schlaflose
Nächte ein die Helden von Rhodos im
Kampf gegen die Flammen die Ortschaft
war die konnten sie in den vergangenen
24 Stunden immerhin vor den Flammen
beschützen
das kann doch gar nicht sein das ist ja
ungefähr der erste Gedanke wenn man hört
das Mick Jagger 80 Jahre alt wird der
Frontmann der Rolling Stones singt und
tanzt als seiner Mitte 30 mit deiner
Band schreibt er seit den 1960er Jahren
Musikgeschichte er kann get no Jumping
Jack Flash alles super Hits dabei habe
er keine großartige Stimme mein Jagger
sie erfülle aber ihren Zweck Justin
herlein über eine Rocklegende die nicht
an Rente denkt
[Musik]
keine Frage er ist ein echtes Phänomen
der alte Herr des Rock n' Roll in dem
Alter noch so auf der Bühne herum zu
springen wie macht Mick Jagger das
eigentlich
es gibt ja diese Vorstellung endloser
Sex und drogenorgien Backstage
stattdessen macht er Liegestütze vor dem
Konzert er ist dann immer noch am
trainieren für die zwei Stunden auf der
Bühne
es ist ja eine ziemlich wilde Reise
gewesen für Mick Jagger und die Stones
von den frühen Anfängen und dem Label
Blues Band um überhaupt Auftritte zu
ergattern dem cleveren Marketing als Bad
Boys für all jene denen die Beatles zu
brav waren
bis zur Ausflügen in mehr populäre
Musikgenre und Mick als soloact
aber selbst dann Klang Jagger immer noch
wie die Rolling Stones
danach waren er und der Rest der Truppe
die Gitarren denn mal ein Motten wollen
wird Jagger bereits seit Gefühl 20
Jahren gefragt
das wird bestimmt irgendwann einmal
passieren aber da sind wir doch nicht
ich habe Spaß an dem was ich tue was
aufhören denke ich nicht nach
auch mit 80 scheint sich daran nichts
geändert zu haben
[Musik]
sehr schön Fußball Weltmeisterschaft
Norbert da sind ja die Spanierin ins
Achtelfinale heute eigentlich so echten
fantastischen Fußball wieder ein
fulminanter Sieg 5 zu 0 gegen Sambia das
iberisches da Ensemble hat eindrucksvoll
seine Titel Ambition unterstrichen zwei
Spiele zwei Siege 8:0 Tore ein Team in
top form
Spaniens Trainer horche Bilder hatte
seine Selektion von Beginn an offensiv
ausgerichtet und sah sich schon nach 9
Minuten bestätigt als Teresa aberera
Spanien in führungsschoss nur vier
Minuten später flankte Alexia puteas auf
den Kopf von Jenny harmoso zum 2:0
Gegenüber forderte sambierinnen kurz vor
Schluss gelang albaredonto der letzte
spanische Treffer zu einem klaren 5:0
Erfolg und Trainer Bilder kann sich nun
auf das entscheidende Match gegen Japan
vorbereiten
ebenfalls im Achtelfinale eingezogen ist
Japan souveränes 2:0 gegen Costa Rica
und im dritten Spiel des Tages bezwang
Olympiasieger Kanada WM Neuling Irland
knapp mit zwei zu eins bei der schwimm
WM in Japan zeigten die deutschen Männer
heute starke Leistung auch wenn keine
Medaille rausspringt Lukas Matzerath
wurde über 50 Meter Brust sechster Lukas
Mertens mit neuen deutschen Rekord über
800 Meter frei stehen Fünfter
trotzdem war Mertens mit dem Ausgang des
Rennens sichtbar nicht zufrieden über
weite Strecken wendet er an der Spitze
einer Dreiergruppe im Kampf um die
Medaillen auf der letzten Bahn dann aber
ein unerklärlicher Einbruch von Mertens
er fällt deutlich zurück am Ende
verbessert zwar den deutschen Rekord von
Florian Wellbrock um 1500 Sekunden wird
damit aber nur Fünfter beim Triumph des
tunesischen 400 m Olympiasiegers
hafnerin über die beste bin ich schon
sehr froh aber wie gesagt ich wäre gerne
mit Metall hier nach Hause gegangen
seine hauptdünne Medaillen Chance kann
auch Brustschwimmer Lukas matze hat
nicht nutzen die Startphase misslingt
ihm danach schiebt er sich auf der 50
Meter springstrecke nur noch bis Platz 6
nach vorne der Chinese China Yang
schüttelt sich kurz und darf nun Gold in
den Pfanne nehmen
vierte Etappe der Tour de France der
Frauen und die hat eine ehemalige
radcross Europameisterin gewonnen Tages
Siegerin nach 177 km von ca nach Rudi
Jahre Kathleen die Niederländerin kam
auf der längsten Teilstrecke der Tour
mit über 1 Minute Vorsprung ins Ziel
beste deutsche Katrin Hammes auf an 9
jetzt ist Halbzeit bei der Tour vier
Etappen gibt es noch Sonntag Finale
danke und das sind die Lottozahlen
die Gewinnzahlen lauten 7 21 23 32 35 45
Superzahl ist die 3 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im
zdf-text auf Seite 557
von Westen Regen im Osten und Süden
rechts sonnig das ist die Wetter
Kurzfassung
ausführlicheres gleich von Katja
horneffer das heute journal läuft um
21:45
[Musik]
guten Abend über West Mittel und
Nordeuropa ziehen zurzeit viele Wolken
hinweg bringen regenschau und Gewitter
am Mittelmeer dagegen dominiert immer
noch Sonnenschein und Hitze das war
wahrscheinlich der heißeste Tag der
Woche auf dem griechischen Festland
stiegen die Temperaturen bis 46 Grad bei
uns gibt es noch einige Schauer heute
Nacht am Alpenrand und auch an den
Küsten und in der zweiten Nachthälfte
setzt dann neuer Regen von Westen ein
die Temperaturen sinken auf 14 Grad an
der Nordsee und auch am Niederrhein und
bis 7 Grad am alpenrad und morgen wird
es am Oberrhein wärmer dort werden
sommerliche 26 Grad erreicht deutlich
kühler ist es Richtung Sauerland
Westerwald und Rhön mit nur 17 Grad 23
Grad werden es Berlin Brandenburg und
auch in Ostsachsen im Osten und im Süden
ist es morgen noch am längsten
freundlich sondern Wolken wechseln sich
da ab aber der Regen der Nacht der
schiebt sich dann weiter im Laufe des
Tages in Richtung Osten und Nordosten da
kann es durchaus auch mal länger regnen
bei Südwestwind und wechselhaft geht's
dann in den nächsten Tagen auch weiter
am Freitag gibt's viele Regenschauer und
Gewitter so ähnlich sieht es am Samstag
aus der Sonntag mit zumindest in der
Mitte ein bisschen freundlicher guten
Abend